[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez y hoy los
acompaño con la importancia especial de
que trae este 8 de marzo el día
internacional de los derechos de la
mujer América Latina es la región del
mundo que en los últimos años se ha
levantado con dignidad para denunciar
las violencias machistas y Buscar que
todas las niñas y todas las mujeres
podamos existir en un mundo libre de
violencias pese a nuestros esfuerzos no
solo es esto aún una utopía sino que la
culminación fatal de todas las
violencias El crimen del feminicidio es
un crimen transversal en todos los
países después de la pandemia y con las
presiones financieras cada vez más
elevadas para las poblaciones latinas el
asesinato de las mujeres está disparado
en los reportes y en varios países hay
colectivos feministas que incluso piden
una nueva declaratoria de emergencia
basada en género es esta la solución
pues lo vamos a ver con nuestras
invitadas del día de hoy en el estudio
está Catalina Calderón y quien es
directora senior para América Latina y
el Caribe de wimen Center y también nos
acompañan vía Skype Gloria Camacho quien
es feminista y experta de Ecuador y
vicepresidenta de mecevi el comité de
expertas del mecanismo de seguimiento de
la convención Interamericana de
violencia contra la mujer y finalmente
Alma Delia Murillo quien es feminista y
escritora mexicana ya estoy con ustedes
y nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de este debate dejen sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram nos pueden
encontrar como arroba franz24 es y la
etiqueta es numeral el debate f24 a mí
me encuentran en Twitter como Angela Go
f24 no olviden además que todos nuestros
contenidos o los pueden encontrar
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y también nos pueden sintonizar
en TuneIn
para abrir nuestro cuestionario vamos a
empezar con algunos datos que vale la
pena aclarar son cifras oficiales Sí
pero que muchas veces se alejan de la
realidad primero porque no existen
registros bajo las mismas mediciones o
con la misma rigurosidad en los países y
segundo porque aún hoy muchos casos son
mal tipificados veamos Entonces los
feminicidios en América Latina en el año
2022 México con 947 casos Colombia con
614 Argentina con 242 y Brasil con 495
sólo por citar algunos ejemplos además
de acuerdo con el observatorio de
igualdad de género de América Latina y
del Caribe la cepal en este 2021 se
registraron
4.473 feminicidios esas son nuestras
cifras más recientes pero más allá de
las cifras pues vamos a las causas y
para eso pues la bienvenida a las
invitadas Catalina Empiezo con usted que
está en el estudio Hola Ángela Muchas
gracias no muchas gracias a usted Por
acompañarnos otra vez como lo hacemos
casi todos los años en los especiales
del día de la mujer hay que declarar
Catalina emergencia basada en género en
América Latina
Ángela Yo te diría que en emergencia
estamos hace una década yo creo que más
inclusive pero los números en la última
década permiten ver que hay una
sostenibilidad en ellos y que no están
siendo claras las políticas que los
estados están teniendo para la
prevención Real del feminicidio ahora
tenemos que recordar que el feminicidio
es la manifestación más cruel más cruel
de la desigualdad que existe entre
hombres y mujeres en en el mundo y en la
región lo vemos muy fuerte con el
aumento no solamente de cifras el
feminicidio sino la falta de
reconocimiento del cuidado como trabajo
la falta de La regulación o el o el
determinar la paridad en los esquemas de
participación política y de
representatividad en la falta de
políticas para asegurar que existan
equidades de desarrollo económico entre
mujeres y hombres las cifras siguen y
siguen creciendo frente a la emergencia
específicamente aquí Lo importante es
que hay que decir es que si bien esa
declaratoria puede dar un empujón
político para alguno de los países que
más lejanos están en el marco de mejorar
la reglamentaciones son la
implementación
enmarcadas en políticas públicas reales
las que van a generar la diferencia el
reconocimiento de la crisis será Útil
para generar incidencia en algunos
gobiernos por ejemplo como el hondureño
que está discutiendo una ley en digamos
de de violencia de control de violencias
contra las mujeres que Aparentemente no
funciona el congreso y en el estudio que
tú mencionabas vale la pena hacer un un
zoom sobre este país es el país que más
mujeres mata por cada cien mil
habitantes Entonces esto es muy
importante reconocerlo y ver que esta
declaratoria Podría tener un efecto más
político pero lo que realmente son las
mecanismos de política pública que
implementen los distintos gobiernos los
casos de Honduras y del Salvador son
bien interesantes precisamente por la
alta prevalencia de este crimen
finalmente con todos los factores que
usted menciona estamos hablando del
crimen que es el más brutal contra las
mujeres después de pasar por todo tipo
de vejaciones abusos maltratos y
violencias machistas Y bien voy a
trasladar la misma pregunta para gloria
Camacho La escuchamos Usted cree que sí
es necesario declarar emergencia por
violencia de género en América Latina
Sí buenos días No gracias por la
invitación sin duda creo que
es absolutamente necesario esta
declaratoria de emergencia porque
parecería ser que ya nos hemos
acostumbrado cotidianamente a conocer
las muertes violentas de mujeres sin que
esto
digamos tenga la necesaria atención por
parte del Estado no como bien Dice la
declaración sobre el femicidio del
mecanismo de seguimiento de la
convención de Belén de parada del cual
participo el femicidio es la forma más
grave Es una expresión de la forma más
grave de discriminación y de violencia
contra las mujeres no y y de ahí y que y
que atenta contra varios derechos
humanos no Empezando por el derecho a la
vida
el derecho a la libertad a la integridad
del derecho a la participación etcétera
y
los factores desencadenantes que
justifican este hecho que también como
señala la declaración y en el caso del
Ecuador la legislación nacional responde
al ejercicio de relaciones de poder
misóginas que colocan a las mujeres en
una situación de desventaja en el caso
ecuatoriano y creo que en toda la región
No es cierto yo soy parte en el Ecuador
de fundación aldea que es la
Organización que registra y mapea la
organización de la sociedad civil y
registra y mapea los
los femicidios que ocurren en el país No
usted decía al principio que las cifras
oficiales no siempre son rigurosas pero
también hay otros motivos por los cuales
las cifras son registran digamos los
datos oficiales se registran estos
hechos no que tienen que ver con varios
aspectos desde la la
los estereotipos de género en los
funcionarios judiciales digamos en el
caso del Ecuador
hay todo un sistema de registro pero ese
sistema de registro está
digamos en manos de varias instituciones
públicas pero se basan en los casos que
son denunciados No es cierto que se
tiene conocimiento que están
judicializados y no siempre es así y
entonces subregita porque por ejemplo
ocurre mucho y de ahí la necesidad de
emergencia No es cierto de que se trata
de minimizar para bajar las penas a los
agresores se trata de minimizar para
para digamos no Crear alarma o crear un
ambiente de seguridad Cuando en los
derechos ya estamos viviendo
cotidianamente esa inseguridad no
Entonces en ese sentido Por ejemplo hay
muchos casos que
no que se tipifica que se registran como
suicidios de las mujeres y eso como
sociedad civil nosotras desde fundación
aldea hemos ido viendo que hay una serie
de casos en que claramente hay indicios
de que son femicidio y que y casi la
certeza de que son femicidios pero que
se coge la versión del agresor y se
asumen como suicidios entonces
adelante mucho al tema porque quisiera
que dedicáramos un momento del programa
específicamente para hablar de este tema
emocional que nos atañen a las mujeres
para cometer crímenes y violencia en
nuestra contra primero Quisiera escuchar
a Alma Delia Murillo que también es
feminista escritora mexicana y su
opinión sí o no a una emergencia basada
en género en América Latina
Hola Ángela Muchas gracias Bueno la
respuesta
formal sería así por supuesto estamos en
un estado de emergencia Pero por otro
lado en el caso mexicano es
desesperanzador y es devastador pensar
que se aprueban leyes tenemos muchas
leyes se reconoce como feminicidio ante
las fiscalías digamos la tipificación
del delito está la ley Olimpia la ley
Malena una una música a la que quemaron
con con ácido la ley Ingrid en fin vamos
ganando terreno en términos legales en
términos de verbalización Pero por otro
lado la curva de los feminicidios en
México no ha hecho sino dispararse
brutalmente tú dabas una estadística la
oficial digamos arriba de 900
feminicidios el año pasado pero se
registran más de tres mil muertes más
bien tres mil asesinatos de mujeres y es
muy posible que muchos de esos
asesinatos no identificado como
feminicidio a lo que quiero llegar es a
que el enorme tema de fondo en el caso
mexicano es la impunidad más del 90% de
los feminicidios permanecen en impunidad
incluso suceden ya feminicidios tuvimos
uno hace un mes en una en una ciudad en
el país dentro de la fiscalía el
feminicida entró y disparó a la que era
su mujer y a su suegra y tuvimos otro
hace poco en un restaurante reconocido
en la Ciudad de México a plena luz del
día estas son señales del altísimo nivel
de impunidad que les dice narrativamente
culturalmente legalmente a los varones
violentos que pueden matar y no les va a
pasar nada entonces sí han estado de
emergencia Pero por otro lado cómo va a
ser que eso De verdad
contenga este este esta tragedia brutal
que está pasando en México sin que las
leyes en términos de realmente hacer
justicia contra los femini entren en
este proceso de transformación bueno
Esta es una discusión que ha estado
durante ya mucho tiempo en las mesas de
las feministas y de los colectivos y
colectivas por los Derechos Humanos
podríamos decir que un paso que se ha
dado al frente es que al menos unos 16
países de la región latinoamericana
antipificado el feminicidio y lo han
diferenciado de lo que es un homicidio y
sin embargo si uno lo mira a un nivel
global pues es poco Porque además la
tipificación no garantiza la persecución
del delito Catalina así es y Ángela
volviendo un poco al estudio que habías
mencionado de la cepal y recogiendo los
los comentarios de alma y de Gloria hace
un momento hay que reconocer algo según
ese estudio de la cepal en la región
durante el año 2021 se reportaron 81.000
muertes violentas de niñas y mujeres de
las cuales 45.000 Fueron perpetradas por
un familiar o por
o por su pareja y ahí vamos a hablar de
esos detalles de la tipificación cada
país ha definido feminicidio con con
algunas algunas
diferencias legales y por supuesto está
todo el proceso administrativo que
mencionaba Gloria como en esas en esas
matices que tienen los funcionarios de
justicia en realmente tipificarlo en el
documento yo creo que estamos frente a
un subregistro impresionante en toda la
región lo vemos conocemos los casos
identificamos además como las fallas
estatales están nos empujan o empujan
historias de mujeres que han denunciado
que han utilizado las herramientas o las
rutas de protección y de prevención de
pedido de ayuda y no funcionan y cuando
el estado voltea a ver es Sencillamente
para decir Ay sí Fue un feminicidio Ay
sí la mataron y empieza a ver la
discusión un poco frente a a esas
características propias de el
comportamiento de la mujer las
narrativas machistas que existen en
digamos en en los diferentes espacios en
donde estos temas son discutidos o estos
foros Creo que vale la pena aquí decir
para el reconocimiento de la necesidad
que se tomen medidas
certeras más allá que la suela
tipificación por supuesto ese es un ese
es un primer paso en la implementación
de políticas de prevención de protección
y por supuesto de castigo a los
feminicidas tú mencionabas un poquito
qué pasa con te mencionamos ahorita
Honduras que también traer a la mesa
República Dominicana que es nuestro
segundo país con las tasas más altas por
cada 100.000 habitantes y vecino de
Haití República Dominicana lleva los
últimos tal vez diez años
discutiendo un nuevo Código Penal están
en este momento discutiéndolo el senado
ha probado una versión del Código Penal
que es absolutamente
terrible para la para las mujeres de
dominicanas que sufren muchísimo las
violencias machistas por ejemplo
disminuye a penas de feminicies claro
Porque además es que se enfrenta está
pasando también en países como Colombia
el gobierno o los gobiernos a la crisis
carcelaria y la manera es hacer que los
delitos sean excarcelables y aquí pues
salen premiados los feminicidas y muchos
otros delincuentes quisiera recoger Cómo
se trata la emocionalidad de las mujeres
y se utiliza lo bueno esta supuesta
emocionalidad que sufrimos las mujeres y
somos utilizadas de esta manera para ser
criminalizadas en vez de ser protegidas
y quiero preguntárselo a usted de Gloria
porque usted me estaba hablando de que
muchas veces lo primero que se piensa
cuando se encuentra una mujer muerta en
condiciones de violencia se dice que se
suicidó y no hay investigaciones para
que para que esto sea demostrado en
decenas de casos que hemos visto en el
último año a lo largo de América Latina
son los padres los amigos la gente
cercana las organizaciones activistas
las que hacen el esfuerzo de hacer
investigaciones independientes y con
esos datos salen a los medios y ahí sí
las autoridades judiciales y los
gobiernos revisan
si habrá que investigar que tal vez no
fue un feminicidio y tal vez no fue este
título horrible que todavía se utiliza
del llamado crimen Pasional
Así es en realidad yo quisiera decir
también en respecto comparto lo que dijo
Catalina no tenemos suficientes y eso en
el mecanismo de seguimiento de la
convención de belendo para también hemos
discutido digamos en términos de Marcos
jurídicos hemos avanzado enormemente no
en términos de de leyes específicas de
segunda generación el tema es que
necesitamos que esas leyes se apliquen
verdaderamente y que el estado no acabe
siendo de alguna manera No es cierto
también un perpetrador de estos
femicidios como dice también la
declaración sobre femicidio del No es
cierto que no acabe siendo perpetrada
tolerada por el estado y sus agentes por
acción o por omisión entonces hay el
protocolo
interamericano en el Ecuador Tenemos
también un protocolo interno de la
fiscalía del estado en que se dispone
que toda muerte violenta en mujeres sea
tipificada inicialmente como femicidio y
en caso de comprobarse que no es
Entonces se va descartando esos casos
siempre Exacto ocurre Exactamente lo
contrario y ese es por ejemplo una
demanda que si tenemos una declaración
de emergencia el estado tiene o los
estados tienen que empezar a actuar para
exigir al sistema judicial para no
omitir digamos un posicionamiento frente
a esta realidad que va creciendo
enormemente en el Ecuador y en el mundo
los casos de suicidio ya ni siquiera
entran para investigación y generalmente
son los propios agresores cuando son
personas cercanas a la víctima que
simulan en el Ecuador hemos tenido
increíbles casos el último año desde un
fiscal que la chica parece muerta con un
alambre de de televisión en un hotel y
se suicidó o o otras jóvenes en que
aparecen suicidadas por una bufanda O
sea que se tiró por una ventana de 45
grados que es imposible etcétera
entonces hay digamos una complicidad
también de la sociedad civil para
ocultar esto y por supuesto del estado y
de ahí la necesidad de la emergencia de
no seguir en la impunidad en el caso
ecuatoriano hemos registrado Incluso el
consejo de la judicatura registrado que
hay un número importante de delitos que
siguen siendo tipificados por ejemplo
violación con muerte es un delito eso a
todas luces de su femicidio hay casos en
que están tipificados como homicidios y
no son pocos como asesinatos y el
perpetrador es la pareja sentimental de
la víctima Entonces en ese sentido Me
parece que digamos todavía prevalecen
estereotipos de género concepciones
tradicionales y un tema que tal vez para
hablar lo más adelante que es importante
y creo que es en toda la región el
incremento de las muertes de mujeres en
manos de las bandas delincuenciales o en
contextos de narcotráfico hay todo un
debate en la red No es cierto
Interamericana para sobre estos temas
sobre cómo vamos a nombrarlos porque
también son femicidios porque las
mujeres están siendo utilizadas como
botines de guerra de las bandas
pandillas etcétera entonces hay mucho
que hacer y que amerita una emergencia
para una actuación más firme y urgente
por parte de los estados y muchísimo que
decir por un lado creo que podemos estar
al menos con las invitadas de acuerdo en
que toda muerte violenta de una mujer ya
cumple las condiciones para ser al menos
investigada como un feminicidio y ahí a
todas luces están fallando los gobiernos
y los estados en América Latina y eso
que no estamos hablando del resto del
mundo ahora también Gloria pone dos
temas sobre la mesa primero que las
autoridades están en el delito están
involucradas en los delitos de
feminicidio Pero además las autoridades
no trabajan para perseguir a los
feminicidas y aquí quiero irme con un
dato para nuestra invitada Alma Delia
desde México porque bueno Hay que
agarrarlo de todas maneras con pinzas
pero los datos oficiales nos dicen que
solamente uno de cada cinco feminicidios
son tipificados como tal una cifra que
además bien Podría replicarse en otras
naciones latinas sino en todas o incluso
ser más alta porque aún les cuesta tanto
a las autoridades judiciales y tanto a
la policía reconocer que una mujer está
siendo asesinada por violencia machista
y México además es un caso particular no
porque sea diferente de los otros al
final es feminicidio en toda la región
pero es que las noticias de feminicidio
que llegan de México son constantes
virales y también tienen esta
característica de que son mal
tipificadas hasta que se genera un
escándalo público alrededor Pues de las
muertes de estas mujeres
sí Ángela yo pensaba ahora mientras
estamos teniendo esta conversación desde
que México se volvió digamos un
referente en el mundo por las mal
llamadas muertas de Juárez que no son
muertas fueron asesinadas eso tiene más
de 30 años y lo que sucedió en el país
es que así lo decimos no todo México se
juarizó todo México se volvió Ciudad
Juárez hoy el estado de México que es el
lugar además donde yo nací y crecí
vecino a la Ciudad de México es el lugar
más peligroso del mundo para ser mujer
lo que ha pasado yo creo particularmente
en el caso mexicano es
uno la militarización de las calles y de
los espacios públicos desde más o menos
dos mil seis dos mil ocho el ejército
que se mandó precisamente a Juárez para
supuestamente contener esta violencia no
hizo sino exacerbarla porque poner al
ejército de hombres armados en un estado
de emergencia pues lo único que propicia
es más violencia contra las mujeres hay
un caso emblemático el hotel verde en
Ciudad Juárez era un hotel donde se
secuestraba y esclavizaba sexualmente a
las chicas para luego asesinarlas los
clientes del Hotel verde eran eran
militares eran miembros de del ejército
No eso se ha venido replicando a lo
largo de décadas en el país entonces las
fiscalías las policías
la llamada Guardia nacional o el
ejército son parte de esta violencia
contra las mujeres por eso se vuelve tan
difícil y hay tanta resistencia por otro
lado el nivel de precariedad en el que
operan las las fiscalías
no pueden hacer pruebas no pueden hacer
levantamientos hay un importante número
de feminicidios en México que ocurren en
contextos de infinita pobreza de mucha
precarización y es difícil para las
familias las madres a veces aprenden a
leer para poder es decir si alfabetizan
para poder leer el expediente de sus
hijas asesinadas entonces La respuesta
es compleja porque es una serie de
factores y sin embargo muchos de ellos
los más importantes Sí apuntan al estado
como corresponsable de la crisis en la
que estamos
las cifras evidentemente están
disparadas en los países Catalina Gloria
y alma lo veíamos en las cifras del
inicio del programa Pero además
solamente basta comprender un televisor
y ver noticias o abrir un periódico para
ver la cantidad de asesinatos todos los
días de niñas y de mujeres solamente por
el hecho de ser mujeres ahora Catalina
regresa a usted si la cifra de
feminicidios está disparada eso no nos
está diciendo que lo que está disparado
es la violencia contra las mujeres todas
las formas de violencia y a eso no le
estamos prestando atención porque aquí
se está hablando de un gran avance a la
hora de de judicializar digamos el
feminicidio aunque no sea efectivo pero
bueno ya está al menos en el papel pero
qué pasa con el antes de que se Cometa
el feminicidio absolutamente Ángela
decíamos hace un momento y y lo decía
Gloria también frente a la declaratoria
el feminicidio es la culminación de de
las formas de violencia la culminación
más extrema es la manifestación más
grave de la desigualdad entre hombres y
mujeres que existe o sea es es la
culmina la acción culmine Pero entonces
solo para que valga y solo para que sea
reconocida la violencia contra las
mujeres es porque estamos hablando de
feminicidio Claro que no que tiene que
pasar en la vida de una mujer para
llegar a ser asesinada por una persona
por el hecho de ser mujer en muchos
casos suele ser su pareja cuánto tiempo
tuvo que vivir en condiciones de
violencia doméstica en condiciones de
violencia sexual en condiciones de
violencia económica y entonces esto nos
pasa un tres pasitos más sí porque a las
mujeres están quedan en espacios en
donde se les violenta en muchos casos es
por el digamos la precariedad de la que
viven la disparidad en el desarrollo
económico es un factor importante por el
cual las mujeres se quedan en entornos
violentos sobre todo mujeres que ya son
madres y y no solamente trata su
supervivencia sino de sus hijos pasa
también por la falta de reconocimiento
de las labores de Cuidado como trabajo y
que sean reconocidas como tal por por
legislaciones falta también entonces por
qué no son reconocidas Porque no tenemos
suficientes mujeres que reconocen esta
realidades en los espacios de toma de
decisión y hablamos de paridad es decir
podemos transitar por todos los aspectos
de la vida de una mujer y las
discusiones que solemos tener los 8 de
marzo pero que nos merecemos tener todos
los días del año y es las condiciones
especiales que hace que las mujeres hoy
en la sociedad en 2023 tengamos una
condición de inequidad frente a los
hombres hablamos inclusive educación
sexual integral acceso anticonceptivos
acceso a aborto legal y seguro en los
países seguro se ha avanzado pero es
suficiente no y cómo lo vemos con las
cifras que estamos que estamos
analizando hoy pero sobre todo con la
desidia estatal en la implementación de
políticas públicas que sean efectivas en
la protección y la prevención y la
prevención está amarrada al desarrollo
de todos estos
puntos o áreas de de las políticas
públicas en en un país por supuesto
existen espacios regionales que están
impulsando estas conversaciones pero no
podemos parar y creo que el llamado para
volver nuevamente a lo que nos motiva
esta conversación al reconocimiento de
esta crisis esa insistir a que este tema
debe estar en la agenda de los espacios
regionales pero también de los gobiernos
y que no podemos Cesar mañana pasado
mañana eso es un tema de todos los días
y no solamente el 8 de marzo el 25 de
noviembre es que nos convoca esta
conversación Esta es una realidad que
está afectando a todos nuestros países
todos los días nos queman nos empalan
nos violan no se tiran de grandes
alturas nos ahogan la cantidad de
crímenes violentos que cometen contra
nosotras y contra nuestras niñas pues
son casi innombrables y sin embargo a
mis invitadas les digo pues estamos
todos todas altamente acostumbradas a
leer esto en las noticias y a
normalizarlo como si fuera normal que
una persona como nosotras estuviera en
esas condiciones y violentada de esa
manera
también Es muy normal
esta esta crianza heteronormativa que
nos están dando desde que somos unas
pequeñas niñas no Entonces tenemos que
ser además buenas víctimas Usted qué
opina de eso Gloria porque desde que
somos niñas entonces somos enseñadas a
cubrir nuestro cuerpo a no Buscar
respuesta cuando hay acoso por ejemplo
situaciones de acoso callejero o en
nuestra familia a no defender nos a
vivir en un ambiente que es acosador en
sí mismo pero nadie Les enseña a los
niños a no ser violadores y feminicidas
Así es efectivamente desgraciadamente la
sociedad sigue transmitiendo estos
estereotipos tradicionales no sobre
mujeres y hombres sobre lo considerado
femenino y masculino y Estableciendo
sobre todo relaciones desiguales de
poder que son las que sustentan la
violencia no y no se enseña por ejemplo
vivimos ciudades digamos ciudades países
y familias y colegios y lugares de
trabajo muy jerárquicos muy autoritarios
y no hay prácticas por ejemplo de
resolución de conflictos que no sean por
la vía violenta no en general yo me
atrevería a decir no que que es un un
problema estructural en donde las
mujeres pues hemos sido colocadas en una
situación de enorme desventaja y atenta
contra nuestros derechos básicos y
fundamentales no En ese sentido es
indispensable realmente cambiar esos
patrones socioculturales que siguen
colocando la mujer como una persona
digamos que tiene que cumplir ciertos
roles no solo de Cuidado sino de su
visión de obediencia de aceptación
digamos de la palabra del jefe de hogar
de la autoridad masculina etcétera No
eso es fundamental y me gustaría también
comentar que la retomando un poco lo que
hablaba también Catalina No es cierto
las responsabilidades del estado en esto
son múltiples en el caso del Ecuador por
ejemplo hay un porcentaje alto de
mujeres que fueron digamos que les
arrebataron la vida a través de un
femicidio que ya habían denunciado
violencia que contaban con medidas de
protección con una boleta de Auxilio
Y eso no fue suficiente para evitar
Entonces el estado no está garantizando
por ejemplo lo que manda la ley que no
es solo prevención atención sino la
protección de las mujeres en situación
de riesgo más aún si sabemos que una
mujer llega a denunciar después de que
ha vivido una violencia sistemática
después de que ya se han reiterado estas
situaciones cuando se trata de alguien
de su entorno familiar su entorno
laboral o educativo etcétera Y entonces
el estado emite
estas boletas de auxilio estas órdenes
de no acercamiento al agresor pero si no
da seguimiento Si no monitorea si no
exige está contribuyendo a la impunidad
y colocando a esa mujer en una situación
de mayor riesgo tampoco cumple con su
mandato de reparación a las víctimas por
ejemplo a los hijos de las mujeres
han sufrido digamos que han sido
que han perdido su vida por un femicidio
digamos no entonces las abuelas o quién
se hace cargo a nadie le importa
entonces hay una indolencia del Estado
frente a eso hay una serie de
dificultades digamos que nos llaman a
pensar y reitero volviendo al tema un
poco el debate No es cierto que
requerimos de una acción frente a una
emergencia cuando frente a un desastre
como el que estábamos viviendo las
mujeres no es cierto como se hace frente
a un desastre natural donde se activan
donde se emprende una Cruzada Nacional
para enfrentar este gravísimo problema
que no solo está quitando la vida a las
mujeres que hay
miles de miles de niños de niñas que
están perdiendo a su madre casi siempre
también a su padre cuando se trata la
pareja porque va preso o sea porque se
suicida sea porque está prófugo entonces
estamos hablando de un tema que amerita
una respuesta y ahí me parece muy
oportuno lo que decía Catalina no O
alma creo que era es digamos de que no
necesitamos la militarización cuando
estamos hablando de emergencia no
estamos hablando de incrementar las
armas de que todo el mundo pueda usar
armas de que los militares vayan a las
calles la policía etcétera No es cierto
sino que estamos hablando de un estado
que asuma realmente la protección que
tenga más casas recogidas centro de
apoyos que brinde oportunidades de las
mujeres para su reinserción laboral para
cambiarse de domicilio y todo lo que se
requiere para evitar que una mujer haya
sufrido violencia acabe perdiendo su
vida que lo que se pide es lo básico no
ser protegidas Ya nos quedan solamente
cuatro minutos de programa esto se va a
toda marcha hay un tema que quisiera
tocar y para eso voy a interpelar a Alma
Y es que estos sistemas heteronormativos
no perdonan a las mujeres por existir
libremente Mucho menos perdonan a las
mujeres diversas o a las mujeres trans
Sí este
este mandato milenario de Cómo ser mujer
se centra particularmente en el cuerpo
el cuerpo de las mujeres es territorio
de la mirada masculina desde el punto de
vista médico legal psiquiátrico nos han
ellos dicho siempre como ser mujer en
qué cuerpo y De qué manera y esto que ha
estado sucediendo con las comunidades
lgbt y las mujeres trans que tienen que
dar esta doble batalla no por por sus
derechos Como mujeres y además por no
ser doblemente violentadas por
pertenecer a esta comunidad en el caso
de México es también un motivo de
conflicto es también un motivo de crisis
y sin embargo como yo siempre digo
a ver yo quiero igualdad y derecho a la
libertad y no tener miedo de salir a la
calle y poder decidir sobre mi cuerpo y
que me paguen por mi trabajo no porque
soy mujer sino porque soy un ser humano
creo que eso tendría que ser algo que
que recuperar ya que el humanismo nos
olvidó nos traicionó y Nos quitó
derechos y ya que la iglesia nos olvidó
y nos traicionó y Nos quitó derechos no
olvidemos Aunque hoy sea 2023 que lo
único que estamos pidiendo es eso
bueno ya que nos acercamos al cierre
Catalina tenemos tiempo para una última
intervención yo aquí le quiero pedir
pues su conclusión después de todo lo
que hemos conversado
Ángela creo que la conclusión aquí es
poner de presente una preocupación
importante y y es y es un poco Me parece
muy al lugar la la intervención de Alma
al final del día hoy 8 de marzo es un
día de conmemoración de la lucha
permanente que han tenido las mujeres
por ser reconocidas porque sus derechos
además sean protegidos
Y de alguna manera se ha visto avances
es gracias a esa lucha que hoy nosotras
podemos tener esta conversación es
gracias a esa lucha que tú tienes un
lugar en un en un puesto de
comunicaciones Gracias a Lucha que
podemos votar es gracias a esa lucha que
podemos participar que podemos heredar
que podemos educarnos pero no es
suficiente Y hoy creo que no Debería ser
una lucha a las mujeres sin una lucha de
la sociedad un clamor general porque al
final del día todos tenemos una madre
hijas
hermanas amigas mujeres que nos importan
y es en honor a ellas que tenemos que
ponernos a camiseta no solamente por
hacer los pedidos al Estado que debe que
debe hacer que debe cumplir para cerrar
la brecha sino también y este es un
punto frente al que tú tocabas a las
nuevas generaciones sí Entonces eso es
muy clave para generar cambios
culturales al final de toda esta
conversación gracias a Catalina Calderón
a Gloria Camacho y también Alma Delia
Murillo por acompañarnos en este
episodio de El Debate la gran conclusión
los derechos de las mujeres son derechos
humanos Eso es todo por hoy En nombre
del equipo técnico Les agradecemos por
su sintonía la producción es de este
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera Gracias a ustedes por
vernos nos queremos vivas y ni una menos
[Música]